january 3rd 2009 bitcoin was launched
what do i mean on october 31st of 2008
on halloween of 2008 the bitcoin white
paper was published and then it took
until january 3rd 2009 for the actual
network to launch on that day satoshi
nakamoto mined the genesis block of
bitcoin and wrote a great message the
chancellor on the second brink of the
bailouts on top of that the big question
was what happened to the first bitcoin
block reward 50 bitcoin were mined by
satoshi on that day a lot of people
don't know and we've covered before is
that the first 50 bitcoin in the bitcoin
block was not spendable the way that it
was actually written in the code is you
cannot spend those first 50 bitcoin so
january third the network launched and
of course from there the game changed i
personally believe the world changed on
that day in 2009 so 13 years ago the
bitcoin network was launched happy
birthday to bitcoin now there's all
kinds of stuff that has occurred since
that point what we have here is we have
on the original bitcoin
talk forum this is august 27th of 2010
as a thought experiment imagine there
was a base metal as scarce as gold but
with the following properties boring
gray and color not a good conductor of
electricity not particularly strong but
not ductile or easily malleable either
not useful for any practical or mental
purposes and one special magical
property can be transported over a
communications channel this is from
august 27 2010 very very shortly after
the actual launch of bitcoin what you
start to see is that there was talk of
exactly what bitcoin ended up becoming
imagine there was a base metal as scarce
as gold but can be transported over
communications channels satoshi nakamoto
understood deeply what was being built
and also had the great foresight to
remain suit anonymous so that there was
no centralized uh challenge with
actually going after the creator and so
of course we've got this tweet here from
dennis porter that bitcoin in 13 years
99.99
uptime
10 million percent price increase 716
000 blocks have been mined 90 of the
bitcoin supply has already been mined
it's in circulation 210 e hash
360
gigabyte blockchain size 80 million
wallets all without a ceo board of
directors a marketing team or any
venture capital investment to get the
project off of the ground i personally
think that satoshi nakamoto is the most
disruptive innovator of our lifetime and
i also believe that satoshi nakamoto
should win the nobel peace prize and
also the nobel prize for economics
because this invention is that important
if we go ahead and we look bitcoin
magazine laying out the price of bitcoin
on its birthday throughout the years it
went from non-existent to five cents in
the first year then 29 cents five
dollars 13 816 275 432 a thousand
dollars 14 000 3 000 7 000 33 000 and of
course this year 47 310
pretty damn cool to see just how
monetized this asset has become it's a
fixed supply asset that as more and more
people adopt it the price continues to
go up to
absolutely allow for those people to
hold it on top of this we celebrate the
bitcoin birthday today with a new
all-time high in the hash rate that hash
rate signifies what exactly is the
strength of the network bitcoin is the
strongest computing network in the world
it's the most secure computing network
in the world and as we continue to hit
all-time highs in the hash rate after
that mining ban last year by china we
continue to see that this is also the
most resilient computing network in the
world so whether you want to look at
price whether you want to look at hash
rate whether you want to look at wallets
whether you want to look at various
other metrics all we know is that over
the last 13 years bitcoin has taken the
world by storms toshi nakamoto created
something that is absolutely insane from
a technology standpoint and also
societal movement standpoint the bitcoin
ethos are beginning to permeate
throughout society which i tend to think
is net positive what do we think about
bitcoin's birthday like should we hold a
little birthday party or is this just
another day along the way as bitcoin
continues to do what it does a little
birthday party i think is uh in order
why not i think uh it's it's important
to celebrate these type of things right
it's one of the greatest probably
probably one of the greatest inventions
of all time right the idea and the
concept of it uh and the infrastructure
of it so yeah look it's chugging along
the hash rate is at an all-time high
again the price has obviously
substantially increased over the last
decade and i just think um it's
important to kind of look back and and
see what this was all meant for right
and his idea and or satoshi's idea uh
but ultimately yeah i think it's just
another day
john what do you think
when he published the white paper in
october some people celebrate that as
the birthday of bitcoin ray publishing
the white paper this was all in response
to
pretty much the financial crisis in 2008
almost taking a direct shot at the big
banks and saying we're going to create
money that is outside the system that no
one can manipulate
uh it's pretty cool to look at what it
has done in the 13 years i don't think
today really has any significance in the
bitcoin market per se but it is pretty
cool to look back uh over the last 13
years and see all that bitcoin has done
uh considering the first block it mined
50 bitcoin and now you get what 6.25
every block so correct
it's come a very very long way obviously
the price has greatly appreciated people
have rallied behind it companies have
been built using different technologies
around bitcoin and the blockchain
specifically so it's a it's a good day
to celebrate but i don't think it's
anything to um
like anything like drastically changing
today 20 years from now i think people
look back like man remember where it was
on his 13th birthday remember when it
was 10 years old look at how small it
was it was cute back then now it's grown
into an absolute monster because i think
the long-term trend obviously people
will disagree on short-term trends price
movements adoption growth rates all that
type of stuff but over a long term i
think that uh it's pretty clear exactly
what uh what's happening here